welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz and today
i'm very excited to be joined by
chris etia who is the ceo of engtal
entou are an innovative and rapidly
expanding
chicago-based search firm providing
recruitment services to
the us engineering and industry and
chris has ambitious goals
for engtal and wants the company to be a
hundred person business
by the end of 2023 before chris launched
entou
in 2017 he worked for s3
where he climbed the ranks from
consultant to regional director where he
took his recruitment career to the
states
and along the way won outstanding awards
like the manager of the year award at s
free in 2014.
chris thanks for joining me not at all
thanks for having me as i said earlier
you've been a
long-time fan of the show so uh yeah
pumped to be on here
love it and for those that can't see
this
chris has delighted all of us of his uh
fruity
fruity show he's got flamingos is it
flamingos
uh yeah i think it is flamingos yeah i
was told that it wouldn't be i knew it
was gonna be a podcast so
uh dressed appropriately with a very
moody shirt
love that so first question i have for
you and where we always like to start is
in
in your opinion what characteristics and
traits do you think make up a highly
successful recruitment consultant uh
good question so i think
you know when i look at this i think
you've got and basically a kind of
baseline
of characteristics that i think all top
pillars have
and then i think there's almost various
ways you can kind of go
go with it so for me i would say you
know what i
think this is just a no-brainer right
you know i've never seen anyone be
successful in this job or indeed any job
you know
if they're lazy so i've been you know
being having
um i think commercial acumen and
business acumen is always something that
i look for
um someone that understands business you
know has a little bit of kind of
commercial savvy about them and i think
you know certainly
in the u.s market in particular and also
the way the recruitment world is going
right now
i think being a strong relationship
builder and having good kind of
influencing skills
i think is is really important so when i
look at characteristics but those three
uh
kind of non-negotiables essentially what
you do with them i think can change like
if i look at
our two top billers our company um you
know
i actually they're quite different now
the way that they approach the job is is
actually very different
and i've been tremendously successful so
i think you can
you know approach the role in a
different way and be equally as
successful but
i think those three kind of fundamental
characteristics
you would see in in most top performers
in my opinion
yeah i like that so just to frame this
up for everyone so
um obviously so for the last nearly four
years now you've been building your own
recruitment business
which is obviously engtal as we
mentioned and then
for sort of seven and a half years you
work to s3
um so let's what we'll do first is let's
let's just talk a bit about that and
that journey
um and then we'll go into yeah your
whole journey so far in running a
business which will be obviously a
completely different
experience from being an employee so um
really quickly so just for all of us so
we can understand this so when did you
take your career abroad like when at
what part of your career
of interest uh 2012 so um i
i joined s3 in 2010 in london um
worked for computer futures london um
collision
um the kind of founding team i guess
we're
in s3 um did that for two years and then
moved out to chicago in 2012.
um i was one of i think those there was
about four or five people in chicago
when i moved over
um worked for huxley so the banking and
finance brand and i went over there to
launch the life sciences team on under
real staffing so
yeah moved there beginning of 2012. okay
so being in 2012 and then and then was
you there have you been there ever since
yep yeah so worked for s3 for
i think it was about five years after
that um
came in as a senior consultant in in the
us
and you know like you said kind of
worked up to the kind of regional
director role
and then yeah 2017 um you know the end
of 2017 decided to
to branch off and launch my own business
with the help of
my business partner and investor mark
okay got it so let's talk a bit about
this then so
firstly always interested
mentioned this a couple of times but
sort of outside looking in
s3's got this sort of reputation of
being this amazing company
high standards culture all these types
of things so i guess from your point of
view
when you went into that business in 2010
like how would you describe it how would
you describe the culture and the
non-negotiables
of that culture um yeah i mean
it's a very interesting company and i
think to say it really is like a
you know it's an interesting company to
always do like a a case study on i think
um you know i i think you had was it
ashley lawrence on this podcast
uh yeah you're also i think he described
it perfectly he said the
culture was lacking and not particularly
good but the environment which was
phenomenal
and i think that i couldn't sum up any
by myself i think
culturally you know it was quite
questionable i think that you know it
was
very you know probably unrealistic
standards
um you know a lot of burnout um a lot
very kind of
old-school mentality um and
part of my driver to launch this company
was to
um basically do something different and
create a different culture exactly
love a lot of what their culture stood
for i mean however i thought the
environment was fantastic
you know they have incredibly high
standards
a average performer at s3 would be a top
performer anywhere else
in the world um you know a bottom
performer ash three would probably be a
very good performer a lot of other
companies
um i think operationally they're very
very good
everything from their back office
systems to um you know the
general kind of you know like logistics
of how they run the business paying
payout
but i just think the caliber of people
are so high and when you
come from an environment where every day
you're expected to give
150 you know even if you go into another
environment and give 120
like you know you you end up excelling
so um for me
i i don't it's a um coincidence that so
many recruitment
businesses have been started by excess
three people because it's a
phenomenal breeding ground for
entrepreneurialism for people that
you know want to be the best in the
industry and and
fundamentally i think that environment
and that mentality is why
so many people that leave lester you do
go on to do some very good things
so sort of if you were to sort of bottle
all of that up like what i don't know
what do you think would be the secret
sauce
i'm just curious about this environment
for me a lot of it comes from their
organic growth model i i think
you know and i think it's the best thing
and the worst thing about s3 because
i think you've got incredibly pronounced
strengths
and you've got incredibly pronounced
weaknesses so if i look at my
chain of um you know kind of combined i
guess like
i reported into the same person for five
or six years
she reported into the same person for 15
years and he reported to the same person
for 18 years so
you you have this kind of you know the
top guys that founded the company
people like russell clements and gary
elder and you know i'm sure
and the organization i think strengths
are very well pronounced
because it trickles down into the whole
environment so very hard working very
driven very entrepreneurial
um but also where they lack is getting
those fresh ideas because
you know everyone speaks the same
language they've all been taught by
exactly the same people so
i think they struggle to bring in people
externally because
they they're very unique in their
culture um
and they do lack a lot of those kind of
you know maybe
new entrepreneurial ideas that you get
from hiring people that aren't
graduates so that's why i think you know
in my opinion you know the company
is the way it is because they've had
that organic growth model where
95 percent of the population started as
a trainee and learned the s3 way
i think it's both a blessing and a curse
and you know one of the reasons they are
phenomenally successful but also one of
the reasons that maybe they're a little
limited in in
some of the other you know the other
aspects yeah
that's really interesting so i guess
what i wanted to ask you then
and and i'm always curious about this so
you mentioned how
um higher the standards were the
environment was
so i guess why why was it that chris was
able to land that opportunity then to
take your career to the states and and
not the person sitting next to you
because i'm sure
there's other people that wanted that
opportunity to open up that office in
chicago or
get that opportunity so what what did
you do differently that's what i'm
always
interested to hear i mean i think i was
always pretty kind of
bullish about my own career and kind of
always had my hand in the air
kind of thing like you know i i sort of
knew that like
you know i would eventually maybe grow
out of uk recruitment
because i think the uk market's tough i
think it's very competitive and
when i looked at s3 you know at the time
they've probably had
150 people in the states versus maybe a
thousand people in the uk
but i think something like eight of the
top ten builders were all in the us
so for me you know the opportunity is
it's clearly
i'm you know a bit bigger over there and
i was always just pretty kind of like i
think from day one like
when i joined the company i made it
clear that that was a motivation of mine
i was very interested in one day living
in the us
um at the time it was a bit easier to
certainly easier than it is to move out
here today but
um you know there was probably more
opportunity back in 2012 than has been
the last couple of years
and you know i performed well one of the
top rookies in my first year and would
say you know
i was i don't think i was a top fiddler
on the team but i was one of
um you know the top builders in that
london office which was um you know a
decent size
um and i think i just constantly put my
hand in the air for for a move and
eventually the um you know they said
look like doing socks in chicago would
you be interested in interviewing for
it and at the opportunity and made the
job
i love that so let's um let's talk about
this this change end because obviously
it's had a real impact on where you've
ended up
so you mentioned that you was part of
the computer futures brand but when you
moved to chicago it was a life sciences
brand so did you have to change market
yeah yeah so it's complete change change
markets changed
and um you know basically built it from
from track so
it's definitely a big change and the
first year was a struggle
um you know anyone that's done that
transition will tell you that the us is
very different to the uk
what was the most let's just let's just
let's just dig into these real
challenges then because
that's people really want to know one
that there's other people that have gone
through these challenges if they're
going for them right now and people want
to know
the dark days and how they got through
them so i guess yeah so
what were the sort of maybe top three
things that you found most difficult in
that first year when you
took your career there and started that
business from scratch
i think like you know psychologically
it's obviously a challenge right you're
moving to a new country you don't know
anyone your family are five thousand
miles away
you know you you know there are cultural
differences between us people and uk
but it can be a little lonely like you
know i um you know you've got to stop on
a train and you know go to your parents
teammates and and you know just take a
break like you know your effort
um you know long periods of time so i
think that that's a struggle and i think
anyone that does that needs to be
prepared for that and
needs to ask for help and make sure that
you know they are
um you know that they're vocalizing kind
of you know any challenges
um you know that they're going through
and i think from more of a recruitment
perspective
it was a little humbling i think i think
the u.s market is a bigger opportunity
than the uk market in my eyes there's
zero doubt about that um but i wouldn't
necessarily use the phrase easier i
think if you started a job
in the uk tomorrow you would probably do
a deal quicker than you would if you
started in the
the us is more long-term it's a bit
slower it's a bit like a stephen train
like when it gets going it's phenomenal
and you couldn't drop someone into a us
market and be like cool let's do a deal
in the next like four or five weeks
i thought you maybe could do that in the
uk because it's a bit more transactional
so i think that's psychologically it
almost takes its toll on you
i came in an environment where i kind of
smashed it from day one in the uk
moved out to the us and i was a bit kind
of like wrong with me like you know i i
was used to being a top
all my have i forgotten how to recruit
you started out yourself
um and you know so that was a challenge
um i think the difference is
um you know us is a lot more
relationship oriented
and it's why i like doing recruitment in
the us i think you know
in the uk it's very transactional
sometimes i think you feel like a bit of
a
double-blazing salesman and you know you
kind of like
don't hear you don't see you but just
give me good candidates
in the us it's a lot more relationship
oriented
sometimes you need to meet people two
three times before they work with you
and you need to go into one door a bit
more than the back door
and a lot of you kind of tips and tricks
that i may be used in the uk
you know just spamming mail charts and
trying to persuade clients to interview
handlers without a guy knowing about it
and trying to create urgency and say
look you can't interview this guy on
friday you go into them on tuesday
those kind of things like work in the uk
didn't really work as well in the us
and the most important thing and advice
that i would give to anyone doing that
transition is
you need to look internally yourself and
you need to be willing to adapt
i remember there was a massive turning
point in my career where
i was probably six months into moving to
chicago
i was working you know 13 40 now a days
i was working
every weekend and i was really ain't
nowhere and i was
exhausted because i can't do any more um
and it was absolutely a step back and
said look maybe the answer is not
but work harder right maybe i must be
doing something wrong
and i spoke to a bunch of different
people from other operatives that have
been successful and
basically analyzed my own business and
almost kind of reset and came up with a
plan
and i think people need to do that don't
count broken enough to a tumor
just because you smashed it in europe
you know exactly the same thing you're
going to smash it in the states
you've got to be able to adapt to a
different way of working and
you know trust your instincts but don't
hang your head against the wall
you know you need to be able to change
them and once i did that i started
you know taking a bit more of a
long-term approach maybe being a bit
more
quality oriented versus quantity leading
a bit more on marketing and branding
than kind of like hardcore sales things
like that started to
improve my business i think yeah no
thank you so much for sharing that i
guess
my next question because it it just
makes sense to ask this you were just
touching on it but i guess
would you be okay just to share i know
you were touching it there but is there
anything else to add on like when you
did
have that moment of self reflection and
self awareness to go hang on a minute
am i doing the right thing here seat
help like what were the sort of main
things that
that you changed that really did move
the dial then because i think that's
what people want to know
that maybe can inspire them to change or
try
new things if they feel like they're
hitting the head against the wall
oh yeah i think i think listen to your
customers um you know it's really
important right
find out where the money is find out
what your customers
want and like it's a tough one because
that there's a few like intangibles to
this uh um
certainly in the uk was api's kpis kpis
if you hit these numbers these results
will come and that was driven into me so
much
that these weren't working my keyboard
was two more numbers
and the reality wasn't that you know in
a way it was almost less numbers but it
was
listening to and you know your customers
providing excellent customer service
getting referrals and recommendations um
and you know and doing things that way
it's all different depending on where
you're at geographically and markets and
things like that but i think
the most important point is is listen to
people that have done it before and have
been successful in the space that you
want uh
and to excel in and then be adaptable
enough to implement that device
um you know the people that didn't make
it and i saw a number of people come out
and they were successful and moved back
i think they were
possibly the people that didn't um you
know weren't adaptable they weren't able
to pivot their own
mentality or how they approached the job
to suit the um you know the u.s market
yeah nice and then i guess just be
really curious because i'm sure
this probably seems like a lifetime ago
now but like i think
this sometimes this doesn't get talked
about as much so we mentioned there
this sort of epiphany and the change of
being open-minded seeking help and that
had a real
uh impact like how what is there
anything that you can share
because i'm sure you share it now with
people that you have for your own
business but
anything that you did like personally
that really helped so i don't know you
sit around being
localized right because i think
sometimes we've had a couple of people
in this podcast that
have tried to take their career to
america and failed and it was the social
side especially when work's not going
well right
so imagine like you said you're putting
all those hours you're working on the
weekend and you feel like a failure
and then you've got no friends not your
best mates
obviously in the uk and what you know i
mean so and if did you do anything
i don't know on the personal side that
helped did you was it quite easy to
network find other expats or i don't
know
and if in person yeah and it was you
know americans generally are very
friendly people so
that that helps i think and like that
you know we
um you know it took some time to kind of
i guess like meet my like
real like friendship group i think when
you first move somewhere you just
naturally gravitate to whoever you're
closest with and
you know it took me a year or so i think
to forge like people i'm friends with
today like eight or nine years on
and i think for me it was just you know
really keeping your eyes on the prize
and
and understanding that this is a
transitional period it's not surprising
but
i didn't pick this up immediately it's
not surprising that you know i don't
have the friendship group that i do back
in the uk
it's almost looking at it logically and
thinking you know what like you know
i can get through this um you know
technology is so phenomenal these days
you know you can drop on a zoom call
with
all your friends and family and you know
make i was kind of conscious to not
ostracize myself and and just make it
make extra effort to
yeah yeah build friends and and you know
kind of do do that kind of thing
um but generally you know some people it
just you know maybe it's not right for
them but you know the reality is
there are some people that move out here
do it for a year or so and say that was
a great experience now i'm ready to go
back and
wait for them like you know that's
absolutely fine there's nothing wrong
with that at all
you know i happen to meet you know my
wife
american and i've settled down here but
there's some
plenty of success stories of people that
have come over for a year or two and
moved back
it doesn't mean you're a failure if that
happens um you know but
i um for me i just think it was um about
keeping my eye on the prize
being aware that these are probably just
normal things that everyone goes through
when they make that move
and knowing that career was kind of
number one for me and you know if i
wanted to
truly make a success of myself i had to
just push through and
you know get through it yeah thank you
for
sharing that look i'm i'm keen to start
talking about
sort of your journey as a business owner
but
i just wanted to ask like the way that
you've spoken around like
realizing maybe this isn't working or
like you said they're just
understanding that maybe this is a
transition and sort of maybe not getting
too bogged down in a day to day because
you took a step back and looked at the
bigger picture obviously what we're
talking about here is self-awareness
right and i think sometimes
a lot of recruiters don't have this i'm
sure we've managed people that don't
have this and get really bogged down in
the
day-to-day and stuff like that like
where where's have you always
have have you always been able to tap
into that self-relent
reflection have you always been able to
take a step back and i don't know where
have you cultivated that self-awareness
from out of interest
no i mean i yeah did definitely not like
it's something that you know and then
even now like you know you've
kind of got to check yourself sometimes
say all right i need to like take a step
back here
um so you know it's definitely something
you know i'm still still working on
um i just think you know putting aside
time even as like a manager for example
if you're doing like a monthly meeting
and do it over lunch or do it over
coffee or do it
in the pub or like something like that
you know it just
disconnects you from the you know
bogging down of like you know
kind of monotony um and you know that's
what i try and do
um you know take some time to you know
whether it's just
boeing and you know sitting in the bar
and having a couple of beers and just
figuring out right
on a high level what do i need to change
right now or taking you know taking a
morning off work and just saying
i need to sit down and you know just
kind of again reflect on sort of where
things are at
before povid taking a day working
remotely and being like right
i need to disconnect a little bit i
think those things are quite important
and
from a self-reflection perspective um
but i just do think
it's kind of like a it should be a
natural it should be a reaction for
anyone that's not
happy where they're at today that's
probably the first place that i would
look is to say okay
what what am i doing here like you know
is there anything i'm doing wrong is
there anything i can change
to help my own you know personal journey
yeah and then i think what you're then
talking about there right which i think
is
is the important part is you just you
just said the first place that i would
go is like what can i do what can i
change and i think
sometimes people aren't willing to say
what can i change and they say
my manager chris needs to change oh 100
i mean you know capability and you know
is is
one of the most important things of any
any trait that i look like i should have
mentioned that earlier but
i think being accountable and you know
when i look at our management
infrastructure i look at myself and mark
and
some of our top performers that's a
culture that we really try and cultivate
like if things go wrong don't beat
yourself up
but don't blame other people look at
yourself first and mark my business
partner is obviously you know super
successful guy and
one of the things i've always respected
about him is
you know whenever things go badly the
first person he looks at is himself
and having had the success he's had it'd
be very easy to point fingers and say
it's you as you as you
yeah his default is like you know what i
could have done better at this
you know i'm going to improve moving
forward and i try and
you know mimic that as well and i think
it creates a culture and a company of
people saying you know what you know
this is i'm gonna do my part here like
this went wrong this was
what i could have done better next time
you know i'm gonna i'm gonna change and
i'm gonna do better
and you don't blame other people yeah i
love that especially especially if it's
coming from the top right that it's
going to be a lot easier for me
in your team if i see my manager going
you know what that was my fault or
yeah so okay so you obviously um mention
mark there so
let's talk about chris the business
owner right and the
sort of journey that you've been on so
far so it's coming up to nearly
four years we've obviously got big goals
for this business want to
want it to be a sort of 100 person
company by 2023.
could you just very quickly before we go
into the beginning of this journey like
what what's pain is a picture of where
the business is at today and then we'll
we'll sort of reverse engineer yeah yeah
sure so today
we are i think we're about 25 people now
um we'll be 35 by the end of the year um
so yeah we're about three and a half
four years old
um we initially started in
um uh engineering so um you know more
physical engineering so mechanical
engineering electrical that kind of
stuff
and during kobe that market was hit
pretty
hard so we pivoted into um more software
um engineering so most of what we do now
we're probably about 80 90 software
engineering in tech
um and then we have our um you know kind
of team so um
we specialize in terms of technical
industries yeah
software engineering development devops
and clouds
cyber security ai machine learning that
kind of stuff
um we have a physical office in in
chicago and we have another office
in dallas and we have a uk and satellite
office
in stafford um so about an hour north of
birmingham
um and then we have we will be opening
an office in boston
and beginning of next year so um yeah so
25 people 35 by the end of the year and
then long-term goal is to grow to
100 people by the end of 2023.
amazing so let's talk about the start
then so you mentioned mark your business
partner
um so obviously let's just paint in the
picture here because i think this is
when we spoke preparing for this i think
this is obviously what people sometimes
always interested in so my typically
first question
for people like you is like what what
gave you the confidence and i'm assuming
mark was was part part of that right
because you
you had someone involved to help you
start this business
because a lot of i'm sure you've been
there right especially in the
environments you've been in down the pub
chris look we're gonna i'm gonna start
my own business one day
but i'm billing x i'd rather make that
for myself or that right but how many
people actually do it
so i guess why don't you talk to us a
bit about the start then maybe
i don't know how how did you meet the
person that ended up obviously
um investing in you and the business and
then share of us sort of
how that works exactly and then we can
start unpacking how that first year was
and everything else
yeah definitely so i mean he actually
found me through a recruiter so
um you know mark mark's background
because he also worked for s3
and but many years before i did so we
never overlapped um
he started his own business post s3 sold
it for a bunch of money and and
um you know and then he took a year out
just the covenants and things like that
and he never did a huge amount in the
u.s i knew he was always a goal of marx
to start a business in
the us so he essentially worked with a
internal recruiter to
try and find him someone to launch the
business with him and be his business
partner um
at the time you know i was pretty happy
like mark and i actually had an initial
conversation and and after that i was
kind of you know really really liked him
but i was you know thanks for no thanks
you know i'm in a good spot at s3 i'm
pretty happy where i'm at um
and then he just almost kept like
nagging the back of my mind for the next
like two or three weeks so i kind of
found myself business planning and i
started actually writing a business plan
you know i never actually planned on
sharing with anyone but almost just as a
kind of an exercise and then
the more i thought about a few weeks
later i kind of reached back out of
market was like actually
this is something i'm kind of interested
in um and then you know what we got
a rolling it was an interesting one
because i was obviously on a visa in the
us
so we kind of agreed to go into business
together probably about
six months before i was actually able to
resign from s3 because you have to get
everything
compliant from visa perspective um so
the last six months i was there i was
kind of you know knew that this was
going to be
you know what we were doing and i was
working on it in the background
um and yeah that's kind of how um you
know how it happened
and i kind of hit it off well we
obviously have relatively similar
backgrounds and
and then yeah we kind of worked on it
from you know it was probably february
march time and then officially launched
in in august
love that and then just real quick
because i think
that this advice has been [ __ ] like what
what qualities was it that you saw in
mark that obviously you've got a track
record that that obviously helps with
credibility right straight away
but i guess i don't know what qualities
really resonated with you because i
think maybe
hearing the qualities that resonated
with you that gave you that confidence
or
made you comfortable going into business
with this person could be something that
the people listening to this
could hopefully look for or try and find
them people that they want to
connect with or have involved yeah i
mean but for me it was trust and
and yeah it was trust and honesty like
you know but those were the main things
um you know i trust mark implicitly i
think he does the same for me
and i think it's just so crucial if
you're ever going to go into business
with anyone you know
it's like a marriage right you and you
just you have to no matter what happens
no matter what
[ __ ] it's the ban or no matter what goes
wrong you've got to be able to trust
that your business partner will have
your back and you'll have that back
and you know you you're a team i'm like
i had a bunch of mutual connections so
we knew a lot of people and
i kind of referenced checkmark and i'm
sure you did the same for me like we
both kind of
reached out to people we knew and
trusted and i asked a number of people
that
used to work with him and things like
that i've got a lot of feedback but you
know
he will not screw you over he's very
straight up on his guy
um and you know that to me is is
everything so
i think we shared a lot of our um
kind of core values i think that you
know when you
go into business with people it's it's
fine to be different i actually think
that's a good thing in a lot of ways
because you can bring different things
if you're too similar that could be
you know a challenger in itself um but i
think at the core you need to be linked
and i think when you look at
mark and i's like i think you look at
our ethics you look at our
drive and motivation i think bear will
be pretty linked
um you know and we're pretty well
aligned um even though again
you know we might bring different things
to the table and that to me was
everything like you know
i obviously i was in a good position at
s3 i was
you know earning good money and you know
had a um you know kind of a team i care
about
and really enjoyed working there for the
most part
um so for me to make the move it was
crucial for me that i was going in with
someone that
i i could trust and i knew if ev
you know things didn't go as well as we
hoped you know we would still
back each other and you know it wasn't
just to kind of roll the dice and say
okay never mind because
you know that was my life on the line
really so um you know it was it was very
important
that was the main thing i would
recommend anyone that's going to go into
business with anyone you've got to be
able to trust them that's the number one
thing that
you should look for in a business
partner yeah
so um talk to us really quickly don't
have to go into like
all the nitty-gritty details but people
i i've said this a couple of times now
but
i i do feel like sometimes people have
the impression in the recruitment
industry that if i partner with someone
that
like mark that they're gonna go gobble
up all my profits at some point right or
do me over there there's been those
sort of stories out there so i guess how
does it work are you 50 50 partners
are you like i don't know how how how
did it structure it how did you
structure the business
no so we are and we're not 50 50
partners we have a
um you know we have a different equity
split in terms of the business ownership
um and we basically you know
mark was um you know more of a i don't
say like asylum partner because um you
know he's very involved in the business
but
the idea is you know he hired me paid me
a salary and as an employee
and then i have a large and you know
kind of equity stake um you know
in the business at the same time and
then we kind of take our dividends
um you know based on that split um you
know i think for me
it was definitely a question of like
should i just do this on my own because
yeah there is an answer you know if you
make a massive success of it then you
know yes you will make more money
if it's just you um but i think you know
you've also got to value the expertise
that someone like that brings to the
table um and for me
you know i kind of figured right you
know if i can grow
my business three times as fast you know
with
an investor you know done to their cash
but also in terms of their
expertise their compact book just
someone could bounce ideas off and
things like that
um you know then i would probably be
about as you know financially about as
far as i was if i
you know just did it myself um i think
if if finances are your
only real motivator and you are a super
bella so you're someone that can fit a
million bucks a year personally
um maybe original argument you should do
on your own
um you know you will probably make more
money
um you know if you again you want to not
massively scale it and
and you know yourself for me i didn't
really want to do that like you know i
would
rather have a smaller chunk of 100
business that is
you know a fantastic culture creates
opportunity for people
um you know brings people over to the us
gives phenomenal customer service like
things like that probably more important
to me than
you know running you know owning a
hundred percent of a ten-person business
that might be
super profitable but doesn't achieve the
other things i wanted to achieve
um so when i looked at things and it was
something i thought about very
seriously like should i go in on my own
and do it
i decided to go in with an investor
because
i just i i wanted to have you know i
wanted to have a business partner
and i thought it would help me build the
company that i wanted to build
even if i had a slightly smaller piece
of the pie basically
yeah thank you and again that that it's
that self-awareness right on
understanding what yeah would be more
meaningful you and what
yeah so i love that so i guess let's
talk so how
difficult obviously you've got that
business partner
it's been obviously planned for a while
like talk to us about that first year
how how difficult was it obviously i
mean obviously you would have had
covenants
so i'm assuming did you have to build up
a market from scratch
like what what was the strategy yeah so
yeah i had confidence um we um it was
hard
um you know it was very hard and it
taught me
and mark i think a lot um you know it
was
one of if not the most developmental
years of my career
um and you know i think the truth we
made a lot of mistakes
um you know we survived and we did um
you know i think we did
750k roughly in revenue or something so
you know not horrible first year but by
any means um you know it was
we we kind of did what we needed to do i
think which is prove the concept
get the business off the ground and it
was definitely a challenge
and you know i think you know there are
things i wouldn't i would do differently
if
i'm you know i did it again um but at
the same time it was phenomenally
exciting like you know
being able to create a culture bringing
people um together on on this journey
um you know and and basically just
proving the concept that it works i
think biggest here as an entrepreneur is
going into it and thinking it's going to
fail it's just going to fall on his ass
and
you know i'm never going to make this
work and seeing coming to the end of the
year and seeing fields coming up and you
know
making even and then making profit and
then kind of you know doing all of those
things and
starting to think wow i can actually
turn this into a real business
started to get really exciting and then
you know we'll decide to really progress
from there
so people listen to his podcast because
they want to know what you would do
differently
chris what what is it what would you do
differently then
do you think um yeah no so i think i
would have done different markets so
um you know i kind of went with what i
knew
which is um you know basically midwest
which is the kind of central
america um and engineering um thieves
were
low for the u.s like 18 to 20 000
um and um just kind of a bit more like
old-school blue collar
type customers like very ingrained in
manufacturing
um just kind of you know maybe not the
most innovative ammunit customers in the
world
so but during cobin and you know it's
crazy to say this but i always say i
think covered kind of
accelerated our business like you
wouldn't believe um because it forced us
to pivot into
um you know kind of other more
innovative areas
now you know we work a lot in tech our
average fees
35 to 40 grand you know and the markets
are just like
night and day so marcus would be one and
secondly i would have led
and hired more experienced people early
and
my first kind of five or six hires were
all trainees and great people very
talented hard working like you know
love them to bits but i think we might
hired
a a right hand man or woman at that time
someone with you know kind of even two
three years of really good recruiting
experience
maybe them a bit more to be more of a
kind of yeah like a right-hand person to
me and
i think would have helped us like now
we've got more of an infrastructure
we have a bit more leadership we've got
some phenomenal villas um
and you know it took us a couple of
years i think to really
almost get the right people on on the
bus and so those are probably you know
markets and then leading with
having you know one or two very good
experienced people are probably the big
dangers i would have made
yeah yeah really really interesting
thank you for being um
honest there so so where where was you
then like in terms of the amount of
people by the end of year one then
out of interest i think end of year one
we are probably at about
six or seven i want to say um yeah
roughly
around that okay so what
what i was just keen to ask you on on
this point because i think it will go
quite i'm really curious around
this this pivot that you had to make
because i i think that's because i'm
assuming
until sort of covered here you was
operating in those blue collar markets
right and then yeah okay so that's
really interesting right so
but so i guess in before that i guess
it'd be really great i'll get a lot of
messages
from people that are really interested
in hearing and really understanding like
what are the nuances of the us market
that i need to understand or
like like what do i what am i going to
learn the hard way
and then look back and six months ago
yeah like that you this is how you got
to do it in u.s so i guess
like i don't know what are some of the
sort of core nuances that
us uk-based recruiters that a lot of
people do want to come over to the us
and a lot of
like i would say most businesses
ambitious progressive businesses before
covert here
would have had us on on their business
plan i think a lot of businesses
still do so i guess i don't know before
we go into
that pivot and and how you approach that
like what what are the nuances we need
to understand what we've typically heard
on this this
podcast is um the the directness of of
people
and we've heard around um actually the
actual
profession being a recruitment
consultant has a better reputation
in the us like what are some of the
nuances that you'll maybe
you make sure you communicate to your
guys in the uk that work for you that
they may have to learn the hard way
yeah i mean i think that you know the
yeah it's an interesting one the
how you're treated in the us is night
and day that's why i love recruiting in
the us i do feel that it is a lot more
of a
a respected career that's funny i
remember i sent out my first mail show
in the us and you sent out mailchimp in
the uk and you know
i can't even you know probably talk
about some of the responses you get but
it's like
no effort i'm gonna kill your family
like crazy just like
big people just so angry you said a male
shot in the u.s i remember when i sent
my first one and the responses are just
like
thank you so much for reaching out like
i am um i'm not hiring right now but i
would definitely keep your contact
information like it
is crazy at how different it is um you
know not the kind of type of question
but it is
it's challenging because you know i
think so much of it are intangibles like
people ask me this all the time because
yeah like you said there's a lot of
people
trying to make a success of the us and i
i have a lot of colleagues that run
businesses in the uk that often ask me
like you know what
you know what would you do here and what
you do there um
i think you know you've got to take a
bit more of a long-termist
approach to it um you know understand
success is not going to come overnight
you know build for year two three and
four rather than year one
um you know build those relationships um
you know
again maybe marketing and branding is a
bit more important than
smashing the bones and kind of hardcore
sales um
you know so but it is tough to say like
you know for me i've been out in the us
eight years now i made a ton of mistakes
um and i
i feel that like you almost it's almost
inevitable you have to go through that
journey like
if you're looking to build a us business
i would almost say you do not expect it
to be successful in the first couple of
years
it's almost like building a compact
business but stick with it because like
you know it
will be successful if you do it right
and you learn and you adapt
um and that's why you know i think i i
hope that we have a relatively
uh you know good proposition for people
and you know whether they're in the uk
or the us
um because we mean we know how to do u.s
recruitment we've kind of cracked it so
anyone that is looking to move out to
the us or just looking to
work the u.s market from the uk and make
u.s wages and make a lot more money
and you know i think our structure and
our relationships are pretty
i don't know do that so that's why i
think you know that's one of our kind of
usps i guess to anyone in in the um you
know the uk is that
we really understand the us market but
it's taking a long time to
to do that but we're in a we're in a
position now where we can't
know how to be successful in this space
so um
if i'm listening right now and i speak
to people that i know that are going for
this at the moment i'm a
i'm a recruiter that does what you do
but in the uk
some of my existing clients have some us
operations and
i've put a business plan together and my
business has said look
let's let's give us a real crack what
u.s hours in the uk
um and we'll see where we are in six
months time
like how let's just let's just put aside
a second that we're
we're not doing the completely wrong
things and we're doing more of the
the things that have helped you guys get
to where you've got to
like what would your honest advice be to
me on like the timeline that i should
give it
for me to then go okay there's a
business here or
like maybe we should actually pivot or
look at different things roughly
would you say timelines i would look at
um in the first two months i think you
should look at
a tangible output you know we're going
to lead to results
how many terms are you signing with with
customers and what does the opportunity
look like with those customers
how many client meetings are you going
on a monthly basis all be at remote
meetings in zoom
how many jobs are you pulling how many
interviews you're booking um you know
but those kind of
numbers that you know are going to
eventually lead to um to success
um for me um you know i think if you
don't
see any revenue on the board or getting
close to revenue on the board month
three or four
you make a little concern i think by
month six you should be able to
consistently do
um you know kind of a deal a month um
but
again it's just it's so hard to say for
sure because
the metrics are just so different like
you know there are some markets where
it will take you a long time to crack in
but there are we have some markets where
our interview replacement ratio is um
you know about um you know four or five
to one
you know i i have two guys on on um you
know kind of
uh my team alright you know basically
on the same interviews this month one of
them will build 200k
in a month um you know it's two hundred
thousand dollars in a month and the
other one that may not do a deal with
the same volume of interviews
the markets are very very different we
have some that are you know interview
replacement ratio four or five
interviews
you're doing a deal you've got something
you know you need to book 50 interviews
in a month to do a couple of deals
so it is very very different and there
isn't a kind of one-size-fits-all
mentality
that's why that listening to the market
listening to your customers being
adaptable
those kind of things i think are really
crucial
fair enough so let's so look we've got
sort of 15 or so minutes left here right
so
i want to talk to you about your journey
so far in in hiring and growing this
american business because again
a lot of business owners i speak to
really struggle on the hiring side
obviously ironically recruitment
business can't recruit for their own
recruitment company right
always hear it but talk to us a bit
about
what was like i really respect that you
you pivoted this business right and
because i think again it's
you've taken accountability like you
you've really shown that
because i think a lot of people could
have gone well we'll wait and
cover this happen so we're not going to
do this or we can't do this so
like what was the approach then because
you've gone from being a business that
supported a completely different sector
right
to then doing engineering in the tech
space which is completely different
and although it's engineering but like
what was the approach like how how did
you get because i'm assuming you then
had to build all again
from scratch yeah i mean we we invest a
ton in technology so
um yeah that helps like you know we're
massive geeks when it comes to tech like
you know i think there's a lot of you
know companies out there
you know the old kind of like there's a
yellow pages and a phone book like get
dialing kind of thing
and whereas with us like we invest a lot
in branding a lot of marketing
a lot in tools where you can ramp up
very quickly so
you know you can add thousands of
managers onto the system very quickly
with phenomenal data integrity
um you can um you know get out and reach
people you know with
really compelling products quickly so i
do think
that investment in tech helps with the
ramp up period
um you know for um yeah for us
um but it was kind of necessity due to
cobin obviously cobit hair
you know we were in a point where every
single thing in our pipeline basically
was put on hold
um and we basically heard like a you
know a team-wide meeting where we were a
bit transparent with everyone and we
said look
this is where we're at this is the
amount of money we have in the bank
which is what our break-even point is on
a monthly basis
and this is what we've got to do to
survive um
and you know we didn't lay anyone off
you know we said like look i will
you know buck said i'm not taking any
money out of this business nor nor would
i
you know i said i will happily take a
paper before anyone else loses their job
um
and um you know but we need to do this
and we've got to pivot and we've got to
pivot quickly
um and the team responded phenomenally
um you know
we doubled in size over cobia um we
you know we made a huge success um you
know kind of a
business and i think it was almost uh
you know
we were doing maybe a lot of the same
things but i think everyone really
bought into the vision that they saw as
almost an opportunity where you know
kind of a lot of companies were
furloughing people and laying people off
you were able to hire some of those
people so like you said it's always a
challenge getting good talent but
over that kobe period we were actually
able to bring in some really exceptional
talent
and we opened our uk office during that
time period which has been
a huge success for us and some of the
people you know we took people that have
been
furloughed in the uk and they've brought
them on board and
they tripled their earnings within the
first year of joining us because the
markets were working and
things like that so it was almost like a
mentality shift of like look this is why
we've got to do this we've got to make a
success of it
and and we were able to bring in some
really good talent
because maybe some other companies were
struggling at the time
fair enough and look people where people
always want to know this and mess with
me so but i hope you're okay
and sharing but people love to know what
what tools people use
what what are some of the tools that
you've invested in that you spent really
highly of that
that's really helped so for us it's
almost like a
kind of tech stack so we use uh we use
our drone we use a tool called
um seamless ai we use zoom info um
you know we just we're currently in the
process using
um onboarding cube19 um we
we have source breaker like it's kind of
like everything you know in
surveillable we essentially invest in
and i think the key thing for us
is that a lot of these tools are great
in isolation but you always need them in
a text app so you need like
the one tool is way more effective if
you use it alongside something else yeah
and i think that you know there's a lot
of companies out there that are just
kind of scale scale scale
for us we try and stay probably a head
count or two
behind where we could be and then invest
that money in technology
so when someone comes in make sure that
they have every tool they could need to
be successful
i promise it'll pay for itself and if
you you know i wouldn't you know maybe
suggest doing that but like if you've
fired your worst person and you invested
that money
in making everyone else in your business
better technology i think
that would be a smart decision um and
you know
we you know we better hardly ever fire
people but like
but we almost have that mentality with
my head like you know rather than
being as big as we could be we try and
be a little bit behind and then
investing and making sure everyone has
a ton of technology um because i just
think it pays for itself like 10 times
over if you do that
yeah nice so look on on the hiring piece
then so you you've got some big
ambitious goals
right um to get to 100 people
when i've sort of interviewed people on
here who
have ended up in america one of their
biggest challenges which is quite
nuanced actually is that
obviously agency recruitment in the us
is is completely different right so
obviously the typical story
um in terms of how how it's perceived
from the younger generation from what i
understand so
see for a lot of us we may end up in
there falling straight out of uni blah
blah blah
but in in america obviously from what i
understand crippling if i'm wrong
so there's this whole a really lucrative
career
for on the co as a corporate recruiter
right and you get all the benefits the
medical care and all these types of
things
so when uh chris is then speaking to me
as a
american citizen you're going look
you're gonna have a lower base salary
you're going to be on a higher
commission like i don't know what's been
your journey in actually hiring
like american citizens and what have you
learned because that that seems to be
a sort of sometimes a challenge that uk
businesses miss because they
try and go down that same model and then
they're like [ __ ] we're not in actually
a very good location
and two obviously we're we have to offer
lower salaries because the
the commission earnings there but that
isn't i don't know that doesn't seem to
be as common
yeah i mean i think it's true i mean
very very different i mean for us
you know what we have um my vision for
the company i've got it kind of on my
linkedin is to
build the best company to work for in
the world um you know i don't know if
you've ever read simon cynic's book
start with why
um yeah that's right by why um you know
i guess is to build a company that is
just phenomenal
um but i think a lot of it is that you
have to have a compelling proposition
and you know you you know we have a you
know we have a five-star glass store we
were
ranked we were named the number one
company to work for in chicago last year
um and i think that you know you have to
um have something that's very compelling
because if you don't
you're never gonna hire anyone because
the competition is so high
and so for us yeah you know our base
salaries are probably slightly lower
than some of the internal recruitment
roles
that you'd get in the us i think our
culture is second to none you know we
have
super high staff attention we never lose
people um
and you know i think that that is um you
know it is outstanding
i think when you look at our total comp
package like a lot of our you know
performers uh you know they're making
five six seven hundred days some you
know some are on track to make
you know fulfill a million bucks this
um so i think that you know you've got
to have like a very very compelling
um opportunity for um you know for those
people
um you know we also leverage uh people
in the uk obviously we have a satellite
office in the uk which
we kind of use as a feeder club to the
us for anyone that wants to move here
but we also use it as a very like
long-term opportunity for people if they
don't want to move to the us if they
want to
make very good money they want to have
flexible working hours they want to have
a bit more of a
maybe a grown-up environment than some
of the uk recruitment companies
it can be a good option and the final
thing is we're shipping to a
you know a remote model we always want
about
75 percent of our people to be based in
our hubs
so chicago dallas stafford in the uk
boston um but we will we will also have
25 30
fully remote so when we see someone that
we really really like
even if they are based somewhere we've
recently hired a gentleman in
philadelphia we've just had a new head
of contracts
and he's based in kansas city um and you
know
we've kind of built this doom culture
whereby you know they can
still interact very well with the wider
population
um but it is definitely you know it's
one of the biggest challenges and i
think
you know that's one of the areas that i
take almost as my
job is to attract great people to our
company like that's how
one of the main components i see of my
position is
creating a company that's going to
attract those great people because if
you do that and a lot of the rest will
kind of you know to take care of itself
but
it was your question is definitely a
challenge of the us market
because there's also not many um
the u.s recruitment market is obviously
a lot more you know in its infancy than
in the uk which is a good thing in some
ways because you know there's far less
competition
that means when hiring people it can be
and you know more
challenges you know there's less you
know there's less people out there
and then finally you know we've had a
fair amount of success
i think there's a few maybe uk
recruitment companies that are
sort of uh previously were privately
owned but have been
bought by private equity firms that may
be squeezing some of the commission
um so the compensation is starting to
drop we've had some quite good success
taking people from some of those larger
organizations that have maybe gone on
the journey over the last 10 years
they're now owned by a private equity
company and and maybe the
opportunity is a little different so you
know we've had some success of
bringing people in from from those
organizations
yeah and i think look before we finish
that that was what i was really curious
to hear from you like
um because i'm sure you have this with
your end clients now
and and your your your guys and girls
share this with you but like how
how do you how have you made that how
have you communicated that culture to
make me feel like it's compelling and i
want to be on the bus
through a screen and and freezing like
how how do you think you've achieved
that i know you said that
you've done it quite well but what do
you think are some of the things that
you've you've done really well because i
think a lot of people
really scratching their head around that
and would have found that difficult
yeah i think you've got to be very aware
of what you are and what you're not
um and and then you're catered towards
those people so for us
you know if you are a completely fresh
graduate without any experience coming
into a recruitment company in the us
it might honestly not be the best outfit
for you people like
s3 and maybe some of the bigger
organizations they might offer more from
a leadership perspective from an
infrastructure training development you
know that kind of thing
but i think the excel is kind of those
second
jobs maybe the people that have been in
the company two or three years
they've learned how to do recruitment
but they maybe
want a bit more of a grown-up
environment they want a bit more
high-growth company
you know we specialize in we have a
phenomenal training program
that specializes in taking people from
uh 200k
builders to half a million dollar
billers which we we pay
um you know an external company to do
for us um
so i think all of that stuff is again it
comes down to like
you know what you know what are you and
what are you not like
what what type of people would thrive in
the environment that
you've created um you know for us our
three core values of positivity driving
innovation
i think if you are a positive driven
innovative
person you will thrive in in the
environment you know that
you've created and from more of a
logistics perspective but we
you know we invest a lot in trips we do
happy hours we do team lunches
we do we had like a wellness consultant
that came and spoke to us all last week
about
staying mentally and physically healthy
during lockdown
um we did like a team yoga class um you
know
the a couple of weeks ago which i was
terrible at and but we do like various
kind of you know like pumpkins like that
try and keep the culture going until we
were able to
physically kind of you know move into an
office um you know
together yeah fair enough so look before
i ask you some
sort of quick fire questions then um
i've got two questions for you
one there there's a lot of recruitment
business owners the
the um i know and speak to the sort of
find themselves in a bit of a yo-yo of
like getting to 15 people then back to
10 or 8 and 15 and back down like
what would your advice be for um
recruitment business owners listening to
this that
really want to grow their team from x
to x and the sort of journey that you're
on what are some of them maybe like top
three tips
for me if i'm listening to this if i
really want to get to 25 heads and
beyond if i'm
always back and forth between 5 and 15.
yeah so top three tips i think you put
work on your infrastructure
um so you know i think people often will
be like
360 360 360 right you know you're not
you're not going to get to 25 people
with 24
360 consultants um so you know work
on you know getting a marketing person
getting an operations person
getting leadership infrastructure um you
know kind of um you know
through the door um number two would be
create a culture that's going to retain
people
you know like i said before i've always
said my job as a leader
is to attract and retain the best talent
in the market
that's it if i do that if i attract
people to my company
and i create an environment that retains
them um i think
will be successful um so i think
creating an environment that retains
those people if you're yo-yoing
why are you yo-yo are you bringing in
the wrong people is your culture
just not you know as as strong as it
could be you kind of need to diagnose um
you know
what an issue is um and then the final
thing
i would probably say is i think you've
always got to look
um you know you gotta have a bigger
business plan
i could tell you i'm going to get to 100
people i could tell you all of those
markets i could tell you all those
geographies i could tell you the
non-sales people we're going to bring on
build a vision of where you want the
company to go
and share it with everyone at the
organization so you know they can see
exactly
it's all very well saying right we're
going to get to 100 people but what are
these guys going to do where are they
going to be what infrastructure do we
need
um you know what is it you know
um you know those are probably my the
three things
i would say if you're looking to really
kind of scale your business up
yeah nice and then i always love asking
this question before um
isis and quickfire ones what what do you
think is the most
important action or kpi that you think
contributes to the recruiter's success
that's a really tough one um
the most important one
i mean i think that you know it's maybe
not kpi
um you know but particularly in the us
the relationship building aspect is so
crucial
like you know if i look at the best
billers in my organization i think
they're better because they are
phenomenal relationship builders you
know uh clients would
do anything for them and they will open
doors for them
candidates would provide them with leads
like you know
obviously yeah being able to pull jobs
and being able to go
there's a number that are crucial but
you know i do think for me
that kind of you know ability to really
build and influence relationships is
is crucial nice right last couple of
questions
so first one um
if you could change the industry what
would you improve
um i would remove
a lot of the cowboy recruiters out there
or cowgirl recruiters out there um you
know i think that there are it gives us
a bad name
i think there's a lot of people out
there that are just trying to make a
quick buck they don't care about
customer service they don't care about
doing a good job for their customers
um and i think you just always gives a
lot of the market
so yeah i would definitely try and try
to eliminate them
nice what what book have you read that's
had the biggest impact on you
i would say start with white by simon
sinek
yes great book um different one this one
what did you spend your first biggest
commission paycheck
sending on a really terrible shiny suit
which anyone that knows me if they've
got to this part of my podcast only
they're still listening don't know
um but yeah it was absolutely awful it
looked like i don't even know what it
was
it looked like it was made of like sheep
man or something but i bought it
it costs like about a thousand quid um
and i think i've probably still got it
in my
uh i'm in my code somewhere but yeah it
was pretty horrific
love that final question what what's the
ultimate goal for your recruitment
career or or business
i mean to build the best company to work
for in the world right you know i want
to get to a position where
you know we look back and we say wow you
know we've got a phenomenal company we
treated everyone well
we paid everyone well we trained and
developed well
everyone that worked for our company was
proud to work for us you know the kind
of company that
you know you you invite your parents to
to meet everyone like you know that kind
of thing
if we can do that irrespective of size
or revenue or anything like that you
know i will be a very
very happy man amazing chris been an
absolute pleasure
thank you yeah andrew my friend you take
care